we got this story from the daily mail
republicans tear into biden's atf
pick for bungling definition of assault
rifles dodging questions about hunter
biden lying on his background check
and comparing gun owners to tiger king
in
car crash senate appearance wow yeah
david chipman was confronted by
republican senators
during his confirmation hearing they
excoriated the nominee on his definition
of assault weapons
refusing to commit to investigating
hunter biden and comparing gun owners to
tiger king
chipman deflected before saying an
assault weapon is quote
any semi-automatic rifle capable of
accepting a detachable magazine
above the caliber of 22 that is one of
the most insane things i've ever seen
this would include a 2-2-3 which is you
know largely the ar-15 round
i would say 556 but you know senator lee
brought up chipman's april 2020 comments
mocking first-time gun owners in the
midst of a panic
at the onset of the chronovirus pandemic
said at the time quote
they might think that their die hard
ready to go but unfortunately they're
more like tiger king
putting their family in danger this is
what i imagine like
darth vader would sound like you know
the empire and star wars
give up your weapons you morons and then
you know just taking them all away so
that people can't defend themselves
i think that they're going to do
everything that they can to get every
kind of weapon that they can that's why
the guy's not using any definitions he
wants to leave the door wide open as
possible but at the same time
what happened in texas recently
constitutional constitutional carry did
i read it with state number 21 or 22 or
something like that
i mean that is growing did you get the
trend i can get behind you know in the
80s we had less gun rights
did we really yeah that's crazy i was i
was i was researching the
constitutional carry it used to be in in
the 80s most states
were may issue for concealed carry that
means
they could deny you then many states
most states are shall issue meaning
they can make it difficult but they have
to give you the right to keep and bear
arms there's a lot of supreme court
rulings on this
there's a few jurisdictions but i think
maryland is the only
uh may issue state right now my favorite
thing about it though
is they have this map of the country and
it says there's a color code it's like
green means constitutional carry and
there's tons of states
it means you can walk into west virginia
just have a gun just walk around you
can't brandish it at people obviously
but you can like walk around with big
guns and do whatever you want
well do whatever you want figuratively i
don't mean literally do whatever you
want
you can like walk around and do things
like go to the store and
unless someone you know complains then
you get the blue states
this the color code says blue shell
issue then you have the yellow may issue
and then the red
red so so i think uh hawaii and new
jersey are red
and it says may issue parentheses in
practice
won't issue so places like new jersey i
remember because we were there we were
in the philly suburbs
you try to apply for a gun and they'll
say what do you need a gun for
isn't that what heller in dc was all
about because that used to be the
application in dc it used to be
explain your reasons for needing a
concealed carry
now it's like if you want to tell us you
can tell us
but they can't use it as a condition
anymore i thought that was a supreme
court decision shouldn't that have
struck down those ones in new jersey and
hawaii in that case
i don't know they they they act like
their may issue but they're no issue
yeah so so i went to maybe that's it
maybe like oh okay we're may issue
we're not we're gonna we're gonna issue
they don't so i was told by everybody
you know in maryland and new jersey you
basically will say here's my reason for
needing it or i deal with large
transactions i run a business i'm high
profile
maryland apparently will say okay new
jersey apparently will be like nah
can't do it you can't even pump your own
gas in new jersey i know
yeah yeah you got you you pull up and
they do it for you so if you were like i
want to defend myself against
potentially tyrannical government
they'll they won't give you a gun yeah
i'm pretty sure they
probably don't if you say like
exercising my second amendment rights
they tell you goodbye
later heck yeah dude but this is this is
the crazy thing uh
this atf guy it's it's interesting we
see these stories
the stupidity of this man and the the
sheer like
what's the right word villainous i mean
the guy looks
evil he looks like a if i was if i was
casting a star wars movie i'd be like
that's the emperor guy like that's going
to be
working for the empire the way he looks
the way he talks he has listened to the
permanent frown on the sides of his
mouth or like downward like mitch
mcconnell
some people have that and it's he needs
a mustache though so he can twirl it
while he's doing these
things i'll take all their guns i
definitely
uh as i encounter more and more people
and have greater life experience i come
to understand that iq and intelligence
is definitely on a curve there's a
distribution of all these things there's
plenty of stupid people out there
i'm afraid to continue to apply
stupidity to what
is actually malice right
that guy knows what he thinks an assault
rifle is yeah but he won't say it right
like you said right he's not being
stupid he's actually being very
calculating and smart about it
there was a there was one point i think
like two years ago where they said an
assault weapon was
any weapon that that was semi-auto and
took a detachable magazine
so look what he's saying right did he
say he said he said rifle in this
instance so he's not talking about
handguns
but they actually included in one of
their one of the democrats included in
one of their bills that hand guns would
be an assault weapon like a glock 17.
i remember i went down to the march for
our lives and i asked people
they were like ban assault weapons and i
said do you know the definition of an
assault weapon like honest question i'm
just doing interviews
and they were like yeah you know like
the ar-15 these rifles
and i said are you aware that current
legislation proposed by democrats would
ban a glock 17
and they'd say oh what is that that's
the handgun i'm like that's what police
use i believe please use block 17.
it's a very common handgun and they're
like no no that's that's that's that's
that's not right and i'm like well
that's what you're advocating for right
now i saw one lady on the side that said
ban assault rifles
and i was like what do you mean by ban
assault rifles and she's like i don't
think assault rifles should be
you know people should be able to go and
just like buy them and i was like but
they can't
it's like they're nf they're they're
heavily restricted to nfa items it's
already
you know impossible to get they don't
really make them anymore she didn't know
anything about it
so she just like folded up her she's
like oh i didn't realize you know
you disrupted the protest by your
like journal actual just regular
questions
i mean look obviously when you go to
these protests for gun stuff
i think most people are they know these
people have no idea what they're talking
about
and so you can approach these people
like hey you're really dumb tell me why
you're so dumb and look stupid for the
camera
i didn't i'm not gonna do that i was
just like i noticed you wanted to ban
assault rifles
well uh i'm curious the the national
firearms act basically banned all
assault rifles as defined you know by
the atf select fire rifles however you
want to describe it so these are
basically
heavily restricted and you typically
don't find them in gun shops at all
anymore so i'm not sure like
do you did you want to get rid of the
the the uh grandfathered in
nfa items and they're just like they
have no idea well most people don't know
anything most people
are ignorant there was a rationality to
being ignorant in the sense that you
could have no
impact on these outcomes and then the
impact on you is usually going to be
very small
unfortunately the government reach and
they're the creep into every aspect of
our life and everything has gotten so
great
that that er that rationally ignorant
balance i feel like is getting out of
whack you need to
know more it will affect your life in a
way that it didn't affect you and you
need to be able to take action
what's interesting increasing
constitutional carry states
it's the the choices are very clear now
like i'm going to miami next week i
can't wait the free state of florida
are they constitutional carry uh i don't
know i don't know that's that social
media thing they passed social media
thing it's totally wide open
it's going to be a great time i'm i'm so
excited about going getting out of dc
but my point is is that like people are
moving i know a lot of people that have
moved people that are migrating people
that are literally taking their
lives and putting them in the place
where they're going to have
representation that meets
with their desires and their
expectations and john rob
a great military strategist and analyst
he's talking very regularly and mike
anton as well from claremont
uh in hinsdale hillsdale talking very
clearly right now about
like maybe we should be resorting the
states maybe we should be moving
counties from one state to another maybe
we should be going eastern oregon
joining greater idaho maybe south
western and western virginia joining
west virginia i'm sure there's a number
of
this is hyper this is hyper hyper
polarization so
yeah people are moving and and we see in
northern colorado northern california in
eastern oregon they want to move their
counties together
the state of jefferson is one proposal
or great greater idahos would
incorporate that as well
then you have the one county in northern
colorado that wants to join i think what
is it wyoming yeah
because of like cattle ranching and
stuff that just that's just hyper
polarization
you know there's precedent though this
has happened before massachusetts used
to be
all of new england practically and how
many states are up there now
the uh the there was one other instance
um west virginia and virginia for
example now civil war
it was pre right well no no it was the
civil war
so as the civil war was kicking off west
virginia western virginia was like nah
we ain't we don't want to be a part of
that so west virginia was north and
virginia was south
split split the state in half
rearranging rearranging counties among
states don't i don't think would take
constitutional
amendment or i don't even federal
approval based on the article that i
read from michael anton
uh just the other day i don't think that
matters why not i think if a county says
we hereby decide that we the people
choose different governance
the united states should oblige they
should they should oblige but there are
rules to joining the union and
i think one of them is that you can't
just make whole you know states out of
nothing so no no no no no
right right so joining us is just
specifically about rearranging counties
into existing states
i encourage that why not it's happened
before representation of the people that
you want
there's no reconciling these issues that
we have these are fundamentally opposed
diametrically opposed
irreconcilable philosophies and
ideologies and that
that will precipitate full-on hot civil
war
or or union collapse so
right now oregon there the eastern
eastern oregon is not being
represented by portland and eugene right
and and i guess is vancouver part of uh
oregon
it's like north of portland that's north
of seattle vancouver
no no no there's a there's a vancouver
in washington and in canada
oh it's washington i'm thinking of
seattle yeah just north of seattle
oh okay really yeah i believe i don't
know we're only live on the air with
hundreds of thousands of people i could
be wrong
wouldn't be the first cops
this is i feel the same way about jersey
is that like all this jersey legislation
is basically newark in like jersey city
they're
it's representing new york the new york
suburb oh
all the rest of new jersey is getting
hit with this ridiculous legislation
it it is washington but it's just north
of portland so we were both right oh
yeah vancouver washington is just north
of portland so but anyway how often
these are it's it's very similar it's
basically the same metro so but but it's
not oregon
so these eastern counties are not being
represented so they say we want to join
idaho where we will be
well at the very least there's some
political pressure right
very little but some so the politicians
that come
out of you know eastern oregon still are
like well we can't
do absolutely anything we want because
we have some pushback from eastern
oregon but for the most part
they're powerless to stop us you get rid
of them and they're going to say now
we're completely unrestrained
and have no reason to do any compromise
at all period for any reason
it's possible they'd also have less
electoral power
why would they have less electoral power
well if we're not talking about
counties adding themselves to blue
states we're talking about red counties
democrats would never win again
democrats are we're talking about red
counties subtracting themselves from
blue states and adding them to red
states which would increase the
electoral power of the red state
decrease the electoral power of the blue
state which means
they'll never let it happen if the
democrats have any power about it
they'll never let it happen
although all of a sudden i've been
struck by some great compromise that's
going to involve greater idaho
jefferson state a greater west virginia
a district of columbia state puerto rico
is a state
this is the way that politics gets done
negotiation compromise who knows maybe
that maybe that
maybe that comes down the road but that
would be an artifact of a functioning
white republic with negotiations to
compromise why would the
the wealthy elites in oregon give up
their serfs well right no
it would have to it's not
they won't this is going to be the issue
right yes normally a ground-up movement
so perhaps the reason you get uh the
democrat
establishment and look very much so many
of the neocons
who want guns banned oh but you know i'm
a conservative but reasonable gun
control i'm a hunter i don't think we
should have ar-15s when i
served in the marines you know that one
guy marine guy on
on on uh twitter who was like an hr
administrator
and then says this is the weapon issued
to me a weapon of war and it's like bro
bro calm down
like you did hr okay i respect it you
know because we you know serving as
serving but
you need humans m-16s not ar-15s you
need to calm down
and so but you know they they very much
want to take weapons away because
then it's a steamroll yeah that's a
steamroll so this is interesting
uh there was a meme posted where
somebody you know some lefty
some democrat was like nobody's coming
to take your guns blah blah blah and i'm
like they already did are you talking
about
literally already did so i i so when you
live on the border of
when you're between three states
virginia west virginia and maryland you
know all about how they've taken your
guns away
because i go i go to the gun shop
crowder uh for instance sends me the sig
m400
you can't bring it to maryland it's not
legal so if you live in maryland you
literally cannot buy a bunch of
regular guns not even crazy guns there's
just random things that are banned and
you're like i don't know why
but they've banned them already now what
they're not doing is taking them from
you
the problem is what they do is they'll
they'll ban it and then say
if you've owned it before this date
you're good you know the problem with
that is
share if that beauty shows up to your
house uh you got an m1a
well i found it for i don't know it's
illegal man yes but the law says i don't
care man you're under arrest to give me
your weapon
you think these guys know anything about
what that means what the law is no it's
an affirmative defense meaning after
they take your weapon and charge with a
felony for having an assault weapon
you can then go to court and make your
and plea to the judge please
i i had it before 2013. do you have a
receipt
it's it's been almost it's been eight
years i don't have a receipt for this
lock them up so keep your receipts and
then go to the gun store and get
copies of your receipts if they don't
have it anymore but think about the game
they're playing
it's it's meant to obstruct as much as
possible so
now you know what this dude said this
atf guy he was like i i
he mentioned to uh marcia i think it was
marcia blackburn
that we should make all of all rifles
nfa items
like there you go that solves the
problem same guy said that yeah
this is so i'm with ignorance man no
it's not ignorance no no no no
people that are ignorant in the united
states that are witnessing this are not
they don't realize how dangerous and
idiotic this guy
sounds and seems to be acting you mean
evil yeah if he's feigning ignorance
that's evil
but if you don't actually ignorant it's
just dangerous idiocy
tuna to an extent uh for uh but let me
clarify to for those that don't
understand the national firearms act
basically they they contin they
regularly put items on this list
it takes you like nine months on average
depending on who has to say
six months to a year to be able to buy
one suppressors for instance
these are nfa items you want to get one
takes a really long time so i'm
in the process of buying some and it's
been i think like three weeks
and so now i've got to wait for like an
atf transfer from ffl to ffl
then i've got to get the paper working
to start the process so this is an
extended process because of shipping
which will take
just over a year to get and what people
need to understand
first silencers are not real like
there's nothing you put on a gun it goes
pew pew pew
suppressors drop the the sound enough
to where if you're outside you you'd
probably be okay without wearing
ear protection but you still want to
wear your protection it just reduces
recoil it makes it safer
you know you i i talk to a bunch of
instructors and and a lot of uh
experts and competitive shooters and
like it definitely makes it safer it
makes it
the recoil is better and for you in your
home wanting to defend your home
people people need to realize this
you're sitting outside you're you're
sleeping in your bed
you hear glass shatter in your house so
you grab you know your handgun or
whatever you fire that in your house
without your protection what are you
going to do
you wake up in the middle of the night
someone breaks in your house you grab
your shotgun and then you grab your
earpro and your ipro and you're like
good to go
no you're gonna grab it and be like boom
and everyone's ears are gonna go
you get suppressors and it makes it
better better well these are these are
nfa items
why because people are dumb because they
see movies where the guy goes and then
everyone's like i didn't hear a thing
and then people believe movies tools of
assassination
they believe movies they like man you
don't want to be in a room
like it's when a gun goes off because
your ears are going to be ringing you're
going to be like
i can't hear anymore but people watch
movies and they and they they
pass laws based on movies and i think
that's a really good uh description of
democrats we were talking with uh
we were talking with you know we had
scott horton on the show the other day
and after the show you know we're
hanging out we had a mini ramp session
it was pretty sick i did a kickflip
pivot it was awesome
uh we were talking about the policies of
the democratic establishment
and i think andreas was saying like
they're centrists or he mentioned that
and i was like dude they're not
centrists and he was
scott was saying i think they are
they're like corporatist and i'm like
dude
hillary clinton no politics she says
things that she thinks will get her
elected whatever she has to say
there's no ideology in there now there's
leftists who are like we must have this
and we must have the
you know universal health care and and
cooperative economics then you have the
right wing where they're like you know
free market is better and individual
responsibility
these are people who believe in things
left or right economically traditional
versus progressive
then you have the establishment
democrats who are like what do i have to
say to attract the largest group of
people to vote for me
i'll say that okay there's no there's no
ideology there there's no that's not
centrist
simply being like i'll say whatever i
have to say is not centrism
a centrist is someone who's like
conservatives got a good point about you
know individualism
but i do think the left makes a good
point that we can't have people just
dying in the street like how do we how
do we solve for that
centrists are just like you know kind of
seeing like yeah let's get some good
ideas right i've got some good ideas
there there were centrists there were
and our political differences
were about policy because
both the democrats and the republicans
came with an appreciation of the
constitution
i thought maybe my history is a little
shaky probably look into it it probably
wasn't as
rosy as you might expect but it seems to
me now though that
like we said earlier irreconcilable
first principles of these ideologies now
that make a center impossible what is it
is it the war
is it like some people are okay with
with conquest and some people aren't
there there's like it's not a left or
right there's another there's a
so this is what i'm thinking it's not
left and right anymore i know the
political compass has authoritarian
libertarian economic left economic right
but the damage the that the neocons
are not left or right they're not
they're the corporate uniparty
and they don't have they they don't care
for for
uh any kind of ideological agenda they
don't care about a free market
they'll support the free market insofar
as it gives them power they don't care
about regulation
they'll support regulation insofar as it
gives them power
they want to blow up people they want to
blow up kids why because they can sell
weapons the highest bidder they can
build oil pipelines they can dominate
different regions and get more power
they're like fascists you know to
varying degrees but
it's it's not even necessarily
fascinating because there's no
underlying ideology other than
give me more i want so you've got
leftists who
i disagree with but at least they
believe things
wrong things things you can actually
point to the establishment doesn't care
they'll say whatever
they have to say i think that somebody
might
argue that greed is in itself an
artifact of free market capitalism right
like there's
varying levels of greed greed or desire
or want to acquire resources
uh we want to require resources to
sustain our families and have some
luxury time and take vacations and
retire early and enjoy our lives
hopefully a little bit more than that
it's it's just i think the same
scale to think from that i want to be
able to do whatever i
i can do and then you know more power
more money more power more
i was just studying the the kelsey so
i'm sorry just self-centered greed in it
of itself
is isn't adam smith saying this is the
the key to everything that we've got
going on in a
liberal open economics thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members
only content segments you can't get
anywhere else go to timcast.com become a
member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you